بلا شك ان اننا في اليوم السادس منذ وقوع
هذه الكارثه وكما تشاهد انا اولا في مدينه
اصلاحيه في ولايه غازي عنتاب هذه المدينه
تقريبا نصف المباني التي فيها دمرت وعشرات
المباني
العشرات المباني الاخرى باتت تقريبا ايلا
للسقوط وغير صالحه للسكن نكبه كبيره في
هذه المدينه
يعني حقيقه اثار الدمار واسعه لا يمكن
وصلها هذه هذا المشهد الذي نصوره الان هو
حي بالكامل سقط انهار بالكامل بقي على
الارض لم يبقى سوى هذا البناء واقفا لكنه
ايضا غير صالح للسكن ستقوم السلطات
التركيه بهدمه بعد انتهاء عمليات البحث
حتى الان عمليات البحث ما تزال مستمره كما
تشاهدون نحن قريبين جدا من فرق الانقاذ
التي تحاول العثور على اشخاص ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض في هذا المبنى
التقديرات تتراوح انه اشخاص لكن انا حتى
اكون دقيق اكثر ساحاول ان اسال احد ذوي
الاشخاص العالقين تحت هذا المبنى ساسال
السيد اردال وله وصهره ايضا كان تحت
الانقاض لكن اعذروني الضوضاء في المحيط
تمنعنا من سماع اي شيء ساحاول ان اتكلم
واجري المقابله معه باللغه التركيه ومن ثم
اترجمها لكم او الاقصى ما قاله مباشره عبر
الهواء مرحبا
برنامج يعني
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله شكرا
يعني انا لم استطع ان اسمع كل ما تحدث به
قريب احد الاشخاص الذي كان عالقا هنا لكن
ساحاول ان الخص تقريبا ما سمعته كان يتحدث
عن وجود خمسه اشخاص في هذا المبنى على ما
اذكر ثلاثه رجال وسيدتان حسب ما سمعت منه
ان سيده وابنها كانوا مدفونين او ما زالوا
تحت الانقاظ هنا حيث ارجو من زميلي المصور
ان نوجه الكاميرا الى هناك حسب ما فهمت
منه ان سيده وابنها هم ما زالوا مدفونين
تحت الانقاب حيث تحاول فرق الانقاذ فرق
الانقاذ هناك الوصول اليهم اخبرني انهم
يوم امس احضروا كاميرات حراريه لمراقبه
هذا المكان وبحسب ما فهمت ما فهمت طبعا لم
اسمع كل ما يتحدث به بسبب الالات العملاقه
الالات الحفر العملاقه التي
نعم نعم التي تعمل بجانبنا لكن حسب ما
فهمت
من كلامه انهم احضروا كاميرات مراقبه
حراريه الى هذا المكان يوم امس وقاموا
بالكشف عن هذا الموقع على ما اعتقد انه لم
يجدوا شيء حسب ما سمعت لا حتى لا اكون
اكون امينا لم اسمع الاجابه بشكل كامل
لكنهم احضروا كاميرات المراقبه ويحاولون
الان استكمال العمل للوصول الى اشخاص ما
زالوا تحت الانقاذ ربما يعني هو لم ينفي
ان يكون هناك احد على قيد الحياه قال انه
يامل ان يكون هناك اشخاص على قيد الحياه
لكن الاعمال تستمر بالمحصله ما زال تحت
هذا الركام خمسه اشخاص من ضمن هذا الحي
الكبير الذي نشاهده الان قد دمر بالكامل
هذه النقطه الوحيده التي بقيت
التي بقي فرق او المتطوعون وعناصر الفرق
الانقاذ ايضا هناك عناصر من الجيش التركي
معهم يساعدونهم في عمليات رفع الانقاض
والبحث هذه النقطه الوحيده في هذا الحي
الكامل حي كامل هذا البناء مكون من خمس
طوابق وهناك عده مباني مجاوره وايضا مباني
في الخلف كل هذا الحي انهار بالكامل فقط
هذه النقطه التي تعمل بها الان فرق
الانقاذ باقي النقاط قد تم تنشيطها
بالكامل والبحث بالكامل وجاري ازاله
الانقاض من هنالك فقط هذه النقطه التي
امامنا هي التي مازال او ما زالت فرق
الانقاذ تعمل بها اتمنى ان شاء الله